[Musique]
c'est le président
je suis profondément ému
ainsi que mon mari de votre généreux
accueil
aux paroles nous en rappeler à tous de
et souvenirs qui nous sont chères je
vois à la prospérité de la france et des
peuples qui lui sont associés puisse la
confiance et la compréhension mutuelle
entre la république française et le
royaume uni y aurait toujours
monsieur le président madame et
messieurs je rends hommage à la nation
française je me rappelle le plaisir que
j'ai eu à découvrir ce beau pays pour la
première fois et à cultiver à mon tour
une grande affection pour le peuple
français
où qu'il soit
lorsqu'ils se rencontrent nos
compatriotes retrouve toujours ce
mélange unique
d'amitié de rivalités dans la bonne
humeur
ainsi que l'admiration qui constitue
l'essence des liens qui unissent la
grande bretagne et la france
il y a maintenant 50 ans à la veille des
célébrations du centenaire j'ai prié les
canadiens de continuer à donner
l'exemple en incarnant les valeurs
d'égalité de liberté et d'inclusion
aujourd'hui ces valeurs demeurent ancrés
dans l'expérience canadienne
vous formez encore un pays jeune mais
vous avez déjà toute la maturité voulu
poursuivre votre vocation
au cours de la prochaine année vous
aurez l'occasion de rappeler au monde
l'importance de préserver ses valeurs et
de les transmettre aux futures
générations